hello and welcome to this lesson of
introduction to AWS by the end of this
lesson you will be able to list the use
of Amazon Web Services or AWS list the
advantages of AWS
identify ways to access AWS create an
AWS account comprehend navigation of the
AWS management console define the AWS
global infrastructure and explain the
AWS security measures in this topic you
will learn about Amazon Web Services or
AWS Amazon uses decentralized or
distributed IT infrastructure to make
several IT resources available on demand
since the 1990s it has invested millions
of dollars in building and managing
large-scale distributed and efficient IT
infrastructure Amazon launched AWS a
cloud computing platform to allow other
organizations to take advantage of this
reliable IT infrastructure there are
many scenarios in which AWS is an
efficient option for running web
applications or organization portals
let's explore a few AWS use cases a
small manufacturing organization can use
its expertise in expanding its business
through quality production while leaving
IT management to AWS a large enterprise
spread across the globe can utilize AWS
to deliver training to its distributed
workforce in architecture consulting
company can use AWS to get high compute
rendering of its construction prototypes
a media company can use AWS to provide
different types of content such as
videos ebooks and audio files to its
worldwide customers
based on the concept of pay-as-you-go
AWS provides a suite of services that
customers can use when required and
without any long-term commitments or
upfront expenditure the platform enables
customers to procure service such as
computing programming models database
storage networking and development
platforms in minutes this allows the
customers to enjoy the benefit of low
operational overheads the distributed IT
infrastructure provided through AWS has
evolved with time through the lessons
learned from over 16 years of experience
AWS diligently listens to its customer
feedback this enables the AWS team to
efficiently deliver creative features
and services even today AWS continues to
hone its operational expertise
continually to retain lasting
reliability by employing its own
advances and industry best practices
into its cloud infrastructure as a
result the customers tend to benefit
significantly from AWS these benefits
include the following flexibility
cost-effectiveness scalability and
elasticity security flexibility is the
major benefit of using AWS when compared
with the traditional IT infrastructure
this benefit is realized in different
ways first you get more time for core
business tasks through the instant
availability of new features and
services the traditional IT
infrastructure requires a lot of time in
planning designing procuring hiring and
managing resources second you enjoy
effortless hosting of legacy
applications AWS does not require
rewriting legacy applications or
learning new technologies migrating
legacy applications to AWS gives the
benefits of advanced computing as well
as efficient storage last you get a
choice in running services and
applications AWS is flexible enough to
run services and applications
or together as a platform you can even
choose to run a part of your IT
infrastructure in AWS and the remaining
part in your data centers large
organizations usually prefer this method
of operation
AWS requires no upfront investment
long-term commitment or minimum expense
this is its significant advantage when
compared to the traditional IT
infrastructure owning and operating
one's own infrastructure requires huge
investments in IT hardware power
bandwidth and human resources through
AWS techniques such as auto scaling and
elastic load balancing can automatically
scale resources they scale up the
required resources to fulfill a sudden
demand and then scale them down when the
demand falls without affecting speed and
performance the AWS techniques are ideal
for dealing with unpredictable and
variable loads as a result the
organization enjoys the benefits of
reduced cost and increased user
satisfaction
AWS delivers end-to-end security and
privacy to its customers it's virtual
infrastructure offers optimum
availability while managing full privacy
for customers and isolation of their
operations customers can expect high
physical security and this is due to
Amazon's several years of experience in
designing developing and running
large-scale IT operation centers AWS
ensures confidentiality integrity and
availability of the users data the
purpose of AWS compliance is to enable
you to understand its powerful controls
in action and maintain security and data
protection AWS provides security to
their global infrastructure along with a
variety of features for securing
critical data in the cloud let's explore
some of the security highlights AWS
sternly controls supervises and audits
physical access to their data centers
and network as a customer you can manage
credentials allowing access to your AWS
account access control list or ACL type
permissions on critical data as well as
encrypted while in storage configure a
virtual private cloud or VPC a virtual
network logically isolated in AWS from
other virtual networks configure and
control the operating system on your own
Amazon Web Services virtual server
configure a security group as a virtual
firewall to keep an eye on the incoming
and outgoing traffic for your virtual
servers in AWS state a key pair at the
time of introducing your virtual server
in AWS this key pair is then used to
encrypt login information the AWS IT
infrastructure is designed and managed
according to the best security practices
certifications and IT security standards
these certifications include service
organization control or SOC 1 SOC 2 and
SOC 3 federal Information Security
Management Act or fi SMA Department of
Defense or DoD information assurance
certification and accreditation process
or dia CA P federal risk and
authorization management program or
FedRAMP DoD cloud computing security
requirements guide or srg criminal
justice information services or CJ is
National Institute of Standards and
Technology or NIS t payment card
industry or PCI data security standard
DSS level 1 international organization
for standardization or iso9001 and ISO
27001
u.s. international traffic in arms
regulations or ITA are section 508
voluntary product accessibility template
or vpat federal information processing
standard or eff IPS publication one for
0-2 the industry specific standards for
customers to deploy their solutions
include Health Insurance Portability and
Accountability Act or HIPAA the Family
Educational Rights and Privacy Act or
FERPA cloud security alliance or CSA
Motion Picture Association of America or
NPA a in this topic you will learn about
accessing AWS there are five different
ways to access AWS to create and manage
your applications the AWS management
console that refers to a web interface
the AWS command-line interface or AWS
CLI which refers to a command-line tool
that operates through commands for
managing and automating your AWS
products or services the command-line
tools operate through the commands to
manage your individual AWS products AWS
software development kits or SDKs
referring to application programming
interfaces or ap is specific to your
programming platform or language query
ap is referring to low-level ap is
accessible through hypertext Transfer
Protocol or HTTP requests
amazon offers free usage of AWS cloud
services for a period of 12 months this
ensures users get an opportunity to
experience Amazon cloud computing
products this service is referred to as
AWS free usage tier the key features of
the AWS free usage tier are as follows
Amazon s3 data storage infrastructure
with a standard storage of 5 gigabytes
facilitating 20000 get requests and
2,000 put requests Amazon ec2 for
resizing computer capacity in the cloud
with 750 hours per month each of Linux
RHEL or SLE st2 Amazon DynamoDB with 25
units each of read and write capacity
and 25 gigabytes storage it does not
expire at the end of 12 months AWS IOT
device tack loud connector that can
publish and/or deliver 250,000 messages
every month and Amazon ec2 container
registry that facilitates storage and
retrieval of docker images with a
storage capacity of 500 megabytes per
month
anything that comes for free brings
limitations along so the limitations of
AWS free usage tier are as follows the
benefits of the AWS free tier can be
availed by the user for twelve months
after first signing up once this free
usage period expires you will be
required to pay as you go as per the
standard usage rates any left over free
monthly usage limit does not roll over
to the next month if you exceed the free
limit for a month you pay as you go as
per standard rates and if you opt for
consolidated billing although it is
spread across multiple accounts the
entry is only for one free usage account
the pricing calculation for using AWS is
simple as it provides a simple monthly
calculator to estimate the cost of using
it services it is important to note that
different regions have different prices
let's see the steps to create an AWS
account the first step is to open the
AWS web page then click create a free
account to display the sign in or create
an AWS account page
in this page click I am a new user
enter your email id or mobile number in
the email or mobile number box and then
click sign-in using secure server the
AWS servers verify if an account already
exists with the entered email ID if yes
it displays an error message else
displays the login credentials page
you
in the login credentials page enter the
name re-enter the previously entered
email ID
and the password for your account then
click create account to display the
contact information page
you
this page gives you the option to create
a company account or a personal AWS
account for this demonstration we will
create personal AWS account then enter
your full name and address in the
displayed fields
you
next enter the CAPTCHA characters from
the displayed security image
an important step is to open the AWS
agreement and read it thoroughly
then select the AWS customer agreement
checkbox
selecting the checkbox indicates that
you have read the AWS agreement and you
agree to it then click create account
and continue to display payment
information page in this page enter the
credit card details and then click
verify card and continue to display the
identity verification page before
displaying the identity verification
page the AWS servers verify the entered
credit or debit card details by
performing a reversible transaction of a
small amount
you
this page displays your entered mobile
number and is used to verify and confirm
your identity as you click call me now
the AWS system calls you on the
displayed number and your computer
screen displays a four digit
verification pin enter the displayed
four digit pin in your phone using the
keypad once the verification is
successful the page displays a message
identity verification complete simply
click continue to select your support
plan to display the support plan page
this page displays and explains about
the three support plans basic developer
and business for this demonstration we
will select the free or basic plan and
then click continue to display the
welcome page of the AWS services
congratulations you have successfully
created in AWS account
in this topic we will learn how to
navigate through the AWS management
console you can access the AWS
management console from your web browser
and it's user-friendly web-based
interface lets you access all AWS
services accessing the AWS console
requires an AWS account and you can get
it by registering with AWS
the AWS management console manages all
elements of the users AWS account that
include monitor monthly expenditure of
each service manage security permissions
and creating new iam users in addition
to the mobile browser the AWS console is
available as a mobile app for Android
and iOS operating systems you can
download the AWS console app from Amazon
App Store Google Play Store and iTunes
the AWS management console displays the
navigation bar navigation pane and
current page navigating through the
ever-increasing list of AWS products and
services in the AWS management console
can be tedious so Amazon offers the
following features for easy navigation
accessing services accessing the history
list editing the navigation bar and
selecting the region by default the AWS
management console displays all AWS
services but unless you are familiar
with the position of the service on the
console
finding the right service from the
displayed list can be cumbersome the
feature of placing services in a group
enables refining user navigation you can
view and access the service groups from
the all AWS services section in the
services menu the following is the
current list of service groups in the
all AWS services section compute storage
and content delivery database networking
developer tools management tools
security and identity analytics Internet
of Things mobile services application
service and enterprise applications here
simply move the cursor over a service
group to view the enclosed services for
example moving the cursor over storage
and content delivery displays s3 elastic
filesystem import/export snowball cloud
front glacier storage gateway another
convenient feature of AWS console is the
history list it contains up to 6 of the
most recently used services so if you
are regularly working with up to 6
services you can directly access them
from the history list the next feature
on the navigation bar for easy
navigation is the Edit menu it enables
you to customize the way AWS services
appear on the navigation bar to do this
open the Edit menu and then drag and
drop the service you wish to place on
the navigation bar the navigation bar
appears at the top of the webpage
irrespective of where you navigate in
the console to enable quick and easy
access for example if you regularly work
with Amazon s3 placing the s3 icon on
the navigation bar would enable
accessing the service with just one
click
AWS region is another vital feature of
the navigation bar if you work with
multiple regions it is easy to forget
switching regions and access the
allocated resources and components some
services such as s3 and iam our global
resources and do not require a specific
region to view and manage resources in a
region simply select the desired region
the navigation bar in the AWS console
even provides the option to view and
modify details related to your account
and access the provided support in the
form of documentation training forums
and contacting the Support Centre in
this topic you will learn about AWS
global infrastructure Amazon has its own
data centers across the globe to host
the AWS infrastructure they are spread
across different regions in the world
namely Asia Australia Europe North
America and South America different
product suites are available for each of
these regions by placing resources in
distinct regions you can design a
website or application such that it is
closer to its specific customers and
fulfills legal contractual and other
requirements each data center site is
termed as a region and each region
consists of several distinct sites
termed as availability zones or AZ every
zone is designed to remain isolated from
failures detected in other zones despite
having an economical low latency
connection with other zones in the
region so by placing resources in
different availability zones you can
shield your data site or application
from the failure at one location the AWS
cloud operates in 32 availability zones
and within 12 geographic regions across
the globe the AWS has planned to expand
their real-estate to 11 more
availability zones and five more regions
in the coming year following are the
upcoming AWS
regions India Montreal in Canada Ningxia
in China Ohio in North America the
United Kingdom the knowledge of AWS
infrastructure residing in these data
centers is gained only by the Amazon
staff having genuine business reasons
this is for security purposes the data
centers are secured physically in
different ways to prevent unauthorized
access the AWS team employs multi-factor
access control systems and
state-of-the-art electronic scrutiny
qualified security guards remain at
these centers 24 hours a day and only
authorized access is granted as per the
least privileged criteria the deployed
Environmental Systems reduce the
influence of disruptions several regions
along with their availability zones are
resilient against most failures
including ones due to a natural disaster
the characteristics of regions and
availability zones are as follows a
region is an isolated physical location
or a geographical area in the world
regions are used to run applications and
workloads minimize the gap between
request and response time or latency for
end users manage long term commitments
and tackle challenges of successfully
scaling and managing a global
infrastructure a region consists of a
minimum of two availability zones
connected through low latency links on
the other hand an availability zone is
an isolated location with single or
multiple advanced data centers the
presence of multiple availability zones
enable the customers to distribute their
computing resources among several Tier
one internet service and power providers
let's see the steps to select an AWS
region the first step is to open the AWS
management console
next from the navigation bar click to
open the region selector and then select
the required region
you
congratulations you have successfully
completed the steps to select a region
in this topic you will learn about
several security measures provided by
AWS the AWS provides data security by
employing state-of-the-art data centers
and network architecture with tools and
features that help you meet security
related objectives such as visibility
auditability manageability and alertness
these features enable you to obtain the
desired security without bearing the
additional operational cost of an
on-premise environment AWS delivers the
information related to the implemented
security using different mediums such as
papers reports certifications and other
third-party attestations this
information plays a vital role in
letting the customers get acquainted
with AWS security controls and how an
independent author would validate these
controls
AWS offers several security benefits
provides expert guidance allows access
to different tools and ensures complete
privacy and data protection let's learn
each of these security measures AWS
infrastructure is designed to offer the
highest degree of data security and
robust safety mechanism ensures data
privacy and segregation the security
manager at AWS review and verify the
components on a daily basis plus highly
automated infrastructure helped security
managers and experts to employ less time
on routine tasks and give emphasis on
measures to increase security
AWS provides free access to
documentation related to its products
and services this proves to be an
excellent education and training
material for customers to effectively
solve their ongoing issues AWS offers
trusted advisor an online tool to
automatically examine the customers AWS
environment identify security gaps and
fill them also customers seeking a
single point of contact to resolve their
technical queries can always connect
with their technical Account Manager or
tee-am
AWS provides different tools to maintain
data security the key features of these
tools include ensuring infrastructure
security by providing mechanisms such as
data encryption and built-in Network
firewalls evaluating applications for
weaknesses or deviations using tools
such as Amazon inspector defining user
account permissions and hardware based
authenticators using AWS Identity and
Access Management and AWS multi-factor
authentication respectively and
monitoring and maintaining logs of
access and changes in the customers AWS
environment
AWS products and services cater to
different industries and each industry
adheres to their own compliance and
audit standards also AWS provides a
platform to run the application and
systems for these industries they
automatically share the compliance
responsibilities AWS works in
conjunction with different compliance
enablers to create different compliance
programs that enable customers to
function in a secured and controlled AWS
environment some of the key compliance
programs include HIPAA PCI iso9001 2008
ISO - seven zero zero 1 2013 ISO - 7 0 1
7 2015 ISO - 7 0 1 8 2014 you data
protection SOC FedRAMP DoD CSM and data
privacy
a question that AWS commonly encounters
is when my customers data remain secure
with AWS services
the answer is maintaining data security
is the shared responsibility of both AWS
and customers in other words AWS
implements a shared responsibility model
to ensure the security of data and its
products and services in this shared
responsibility model AWS undertake
security of the global infrastructure
for services that run in the cloud refer
to as security of the cloud where as
customers manage security of their data
and applications using the AWS services
refer to as security in the cloud this
shared responsibility model reduces the
customer's operational burden as AWS
operates manages and controls components
of the host operating system and
virtualization lab to the physical
security of the facilities in which the
services operate customers have the
control to protect the content platform
applications application software and
configuration of the AWS provided
security group firewall AWS provides
multiple data protection services which
includes encryption security groups and
multi-factor authentication capabilities
customers are expected to utilize the
provided data protection services to
deploy configure and maintain security
baselines within the available services
the crucial components of AWS are their
data centers and keeping them physically
secure is their prime responsibility the
AWS team has the expertise to design
build and operate within large-scale
data centers and maintain their physical
security the AWS team undertakes the
following key measures to ensure
physical security of their facilities
and data centers deploying trained
security guards for around-the-clock
security of data center facilities
nondescript locations and under
closed facilities implementing
two-factor authentication to access the
facilities allowing only individuals
with approved and authorized access
within the data centers and providing
non-stop monitoring logging and auditing
of physical access controls AWS services
provide security for all supported
hardware and software products using
different AWS monitoring tools that
prevent unusual or unauthorized events
or situations at the communication
points these tools keep a keen eye on
the usage of network and server port
scanning activities applications and
unauthorized intrusion attempts AWS
monitoring tools are used to locate
different types of denial of service or
do s attacks flooding and software or
logic attacks
additionally AWS implements other key
security measures that include
monitoring and controlling change to the
AWS hardware and software through a
centralized and automated change control
process ensuring only authorized
individuals can gain access to the
supported hardware and software products
allowing access to confidential software
or hardware using only an SSH login this
is accessible only through base station
servers that record all access attempts
monitoring and controlling
communications within the internal and
beyond external boundary of the network
AWS offers different tools and
compliance resources to maintain
security for their cloud-based
architecture and environment the
measures implemented by these tools
include use SSL and secured API
endpoints or customer access points for
encrypted transmission over HTTP allow
only users and software with
cryptographic keys and certificates to
access an AWS API control external
access to ec2 instances using built-in
firewalls called security groups
create individual user accounts in the I
am tool enable multi-factor
authentication or MFA with the help of
hardware token or a software app offer
data encryption of files and objects
stored using AWS services such as Amazon
s3 Amazon glacier Amazon redshift Oracle
RDS and others AWS provides security
groups that work as built-in firewalls
for your virtual servers this feature
gives you the ability to set access
controls on instances of your stored
applications and data you can set them
totally public or completely private or
somewhere in between plus AWS enables
you to control egress and ingress of
data when its instances are placed
within a virtual private cloud or VPC
subnet
Amazon virtual private cloud or Amazon
VPC offers you the facility to logically
detach a portion of the AWS cloud and
then introduce the required AWS
resources in your defined virtual
network this facility gives you complete
control of the virtual network settings
such as selecting IP address range
creating subnets and configuring routine
tables and network gateways Amazon VPC
adds a network security layer over and
above your data instances it creates
private subnets
and adds an IPSec VPN tunnel between
your home network and your AWS VPC also
it offers the privilege to define
network topology subnets network access
control lists Internet gateways routing
tables and virtual private gateways here
the subnets can be defined as public or
private the Identity and Access
Management or the I am tool enables you
to control the users service level
access set security for users accessing
AWS services and resources work with AWS
users and groups set permissions for
users accessing AWS resources create
users and groups to find roles set iam
access control policies define group
functions related to user management iam
fails to provide any solution to set
application level security and control
resource level access in the case of
single user policies iam uses the least
privileged model to aggregate
permissions and maintains a deny bias
let's summarize the topics covered in
this lesson
Amazon Web Services is Amazon's cloud
computing environment offering
significant advantages of flexibility
economies of scale scalability and
security the infrastructure of Amazon
Web Services resides in Amazon data
centers spread across the globe these
sites are called regions you can access
AWS through the management console the
command-line interface command-line
tools AWS software development kits and
query api's AWS provides the simple
monthly calculator to estimate the cost
of using AWS AWS offers several security
benefits provides expert guidance allows
access to different tools and ensures
complete privacy and data protection
Amazon virtual private cloud or Amazon
VPC offers you the facility to logically
detach a portion of the AWS cloud and
then introduce the required AWS
resources in your defined virtual
network this facility gives you complete
control of the virtual network settings
such as selecting IP address range
creating subnets and configuring routine
tables and network gateways
this concludes the lesson introduction
to AWS the next lesson is orge and
content delivery
you